hello everyone welcome to the microsoft
research summit uh my name is josh
benello and
i'm a senior cryptographer here at
microsoft research and i'm going to be
talking about uh verifiable election
technologies and what we're doing with
them and how we're using them uh here at
microsoft
so we have today a crisis of confidence
in voting in the united states
we have millions of americans who do not
believe results of
recent elections
and
it is a problem
regardless of
one's one's view of
this the
particular concerns here
there are a few undeniable things that
we really do need to acknowledge
and that includes that we are really not
providing voters with any substantive
evidence that their votes have been
correctly counted in an election instead
what we ask voters to do
is to trust their local election
officials their equipment
the equipment vendors and a whole chain
of custody that
is involved in making an election work
that's not to say that there are any
problems that we've seen in recent
elections i personally have seen no
evidence of any large-scale fraud of any
kind and i i'm pretty close to the
subject
but
it is something that we should be aware
of and we should try to do better with
the national academies of science
engineering and medicine issued a report
three years ago that went into a lot of
detail on various aspects of the u.s
electoral system
and i'm not going to come close to going
into any of the uh
the details of most of the report
um but
one of the the findings is that our
election systems are today extremely
vulnerable
there's a strong recommendation of doing
the best we can at applying best
practices at improving the system
but this is not enough by itself and the
principal reason for that is we've faced
an asymmetric challenge
elections in the u.s are run locally
mostly at the county level sometimes
even the township level
there are only two states in the u.s
that administer elections on a statewide
level but
the attackers are often much better
resourced than
the jurisdictions that are managing
our elections
uh the attackers might be nation states
or well-funded domestic attackers and
small county governments
just aren't equipped to be able to
handle a concerted attack from a
well-funded
adversary
alex halderman of the university of
michigan um
did a lot of work in the michigan
recounts after the 2016 election
um and he discovered some some glaring
vulnerabilities and he said i've heard
him say this many times that his
undergraduate security class could have
changed the results of the 2016 election
um and i believe him some of the things
he he's
turned up or are rather jaw-dropping in
what
could potentially
be done
now again
i'm not suggesting there's any evidence
that these things have been done and if
they were done they probably would leave
evidence
but still
we don't want them to be done we want to
be able to have better systems
so we should ask ourselves why it is
that elections are so much harder we
don't seem to have this problem in other
areas we don't have this problem in
banking it seems
at one time trust in the banking system
was a problem in the us but now people
seem pretty confident that when they put
money in in a bank they can get it out
anytime they want
shopping isn't a problem when people buy
things
locally online they they seem confident
they get what they want or they get it
fixed it's not a problem
other common areas we don't seem to have
this problem with what is it that makes
elections hard
and the principal answer to this
is ballot secrecy
if we had to have the same kind of
secrecy in banking for instance where
you couldn't see your bank account
um and then um banking would would be a
lot harder as well and other things
so we should talk some about ballot
privacy and some of the the
requirements there because
uh in a secret ballot election we
certainly want
voters to be able to keep their votes
private um that that we view as a
fundamental uh requirement in elections
but even that isn't enough
it's not enough to just be able to
voters should also be unable
to show anybody else how they voted they
can tell other people how they voted but
they shouldn't be able to give evidence
or prove to other people how they voted
if they could
they could sell their votes they could
be subjected to coercion of various
kinds and we don't want this to be a
part of our elections
now
secret ballots were not always a part of
elections in the u.s
in fact it wasn't until the late 19th
century
that um
the secret ballot became used in any uh
large sense in the u.s
in fact the 1888 presidential election
had so much
uh vote
selling and coercion it was so rife with
it that that that caused the entire
country to it
uh in a very short amount of time
sweep in the elect the the secret ballot
and by the 1892 presidential candidate
election with the same two candidates
facing each other in a secret ballot
election a different candidate won the
presidency so um secret ballots are
are very much an important part of our
electoral system i don't want to give
them up even though they create
challenges for us
and one thing we should understand is
the secret ballot processes that we've
used
were a technological advance when they
were introduced
we see this today as almost a given we
don't think twice about it
but the idea of being able to vote
in
a private environment within a public
environment where your privacy is being
publicly monitored and publicly enforced
this was a technological achievement
when when it was first developed in the
mid 19th century
and it spread around the world somewhat
uh slowly it took
excuse me several decades for it to make
it to the u.s
now we really want the kind of
transparency that's offered by a an open
election an election before the the uh
the time of secret ballot elections
because
with an open ballot election we can at
least see how everybody voted we can see
how our own votes are counted we know
that all the votes are correctly counted
they may have been coerced but the
actual election itself we might have
higher confidence in
um so
we really want secret ballots for all
the reasons i've talked about but
there's a high price that we pay
in in not being able to as easily audit
and be confident in the results
really with the current electoral system
that we have throughout most of the u.s
voters can do a little more than
cast their votes and then hope
it's really not feasible to watch the
entire process for any single voter and
make sure my vote was properly counted
you can do some things
you can you can try a lot of things are
done in public view
but even in a low-tech system where you
drop your ballot in a ballot box
um
i i know of very few people who will
then sit there the entire day and watch
that the ballot box is not tampered with
and that at the end of the day
their ballot is is um counted properly
and with all the others and they would
of course have to start at the very
beginning of the day and see that the
ballot box is empty to begin with to
have any confidence so
individual verifiability in an election
is really
not
very realistic with the current methods
that we're using
now we would like to be able to get the
transparency that we had in an open
ballot election the question is what can
we do how close can we come and it turns
out that we can actually come very close
we can do surprisingly well
there are technologies available that
allow
any inaccuracies and any tampering in an
election to be detected
and not just detected excuse me by
election officials but by candidates by
media by voters themselves
and
essentially any observer is able to
check and
make sure that
the votes have been properly
counted with without any tampering
and when i say without any tampering i'm
not just referring to external tampering
i'm also including internal tampering uh
internal corruption by election
officials or equipment vendors who may
have
either intentionally or inadvertently
left vulnerabilities in their systems
even forms of tampering that have not
yet been thought up
technologies do exist today that are
able to detect
any tampering that has happened with the
ballots
this set of technologies that achieve
this and it's not just one thing there
are actually multiple ways of doing this
are collectively known as end-to-end
verifiability
so an election is
end-to-end verifiable
um
if it allows us to
trust the accuracy of an election
outcome
without having to trust
the software that that may have been
used in the system the hardware or even
the people the the people who are part
of running the election
so
what is
an end-to-end verifiable election
somewhat more formally it has two
properties
an election is end-to-end verifiable if
voters can verify for themselves that
their own votes have been correctly
recorded
and
anyone is able to verify that the
recorded votes have been accurately
tallied in an election
so this is about the best we can hope to
do you might ask why
anyone can't verify that my
selections have been accurately recorded
and it's hard to see how we could do
that and maintain secrecy
so in some sense it's up to me as a
voter to make sure that my votes have
been correctly recorded although i'll
talk more about statistical methods so
that we don't have to require all voters
to do that but every voter is in some
sense individually responsible
and then anyone can then look at the
list of recorded votes and make sure
that they've been correctly tallied
so
this sounds like a very hard thing to be
able to do but i'll show you right here
that it's quite easy to achieve
end-to-end verifiability
if we have an open election
now the modern version of the mid 19th
century um open election might look like
a website
where
all the votes have been posted it
doesn't even matter how my vote got
there anymore but we i can see all the
votes have been posted i can see that my
vote is correct i can see everybody
else's vote and i can see that the votes
have been tallied correctly
so
achieving the requirements of an
end-to-end verifiable election is
actually quite easy if we don't have to
worry about privacy
and now the question is can we do this
with a secret ballot election
and it turns out the answer is yes we
can
and what we do is take this model and
just add a thin layer of encryption
at right at just the right point so we
have
the same
website showing all of the votes but
this time all the votes are encrypted
so what do we have to do if the votes
are encrypted to to make this fully
end-to-end verifiable well we have to
give each voter the capability of
checking that the vote recorded
by that voter matches that voters
choices so here carol has some way of
checking that
the
uh encrypted ballot that corresponds to
her vote really does capture her correct
vote
and we have to do this in a way that
doesn't allow her to show anybody else
what her vote is so it's a little tricky
but but not as hard as it might seem
the other thing we have to be able to do
is show that this set of encrypted
ballots corresponds to the announced
tally of the election that there is some
mathematical proof which achieves this
and
this
i'm going to talk about first actually
so those are the two things we have to
do
and that leaves these two questions to
be answered how is it that voters turn
their preferences into encrypted votes
and
how is it that voters and observers and
anybody else
can be convinced that the encrypted
votes correspond to the tally that's
been announced
and for a variety of reasons
i'm going to address the second topic
first
it's a little bit more
formal um a little bit easier to think
about i think
initially and chronologically this is
something we understood how to do first
so i'm going to start with that
so to do that let's first sort of look
at what a vote might look like
this might be a representation of a vote
where there's just
um it's very simple there is one
contest on the ballot there are four
options and a valid vote might be
a zero in all but one option this is
saying this voter can chose the second
candidate or the second choice um uh in
this contest and of course the voter
might choose none of the above but you
know this is
the common simple case
so
in tallying an election we might have
the votes of all the voters
and
if they're all in this form
tallying an election is nothing more
than column wise addition
of these votes we're just adding up the
columns of zeros and ones and nothing
more
really computing the result of an
election is nothing more than basic
addition
so
we know how to do this this is pretty
easy
the question now is what happens if
these ballots have been encrypted in
some way how can we possibly tally
encrypted ballots
so the trick is something that's been
around for quite a long time actually
something known as homomorphic
encryption
homomorphic encryption allows
you to do computations on encrypted data
without having to decrypt it you can do
meaningful computations on the encrypted
data directly in its encrypted form
um i want to note something because this
sometimes causes some confusion
many people here may
know of homomorphic encryption may have
heard of it um something called fully
homomorphic encryption
was developed a little over 10 years ago
and it's become very popular and very
well used
um homomorphic encryption not fully
existed
for
pretty much as long as public key
encryption
has existed the first ideas about
homework for concretion came about uh 40
years ago
um
and but basic homomorphic encryption
sometimes called simple or now partial
homomorphic encryption is just a single
operation
fully homomorphic encryption is a very
powerful tool that allows you to compute
multiple operations usually addition and
multiplication together
and
because that's expressively complete you
can do any computation at all with fully
homomorphic encryption the problem is
there's a big price to be paid it's it's
quite inefficient
simple homomorphic encryption a single
operation is very very efficient and i
want to call that uh distinction just to
make sure there's there's no confusion
about that point
okay
so let's take a look at how encryption
typically works is with standard
encryption the only thing you ever do
with encrypted data
is decrypt it eventually you might
encrypt some data and
store it and then retrieve it and then
decrypt it you might encrypt some data
and then send it to somebody else and it
gets decrypted by the the other person
um that's a very common use case but the
data itself doesn't change the encrypted
data is
static
that's the usual case
if we have
homomorphic methods however we can apply
some operator and i'm being a little
vague here about what the operator might
be but apply an operator to two
encrypted
pieces of data
and
get a meaningful result
and this process is what's known as
homomorphic encryption
so if we have
a homomorphic encryption function that
computes addition under the covers then
we can do homomorphic tallying of an
election we take the encrypted
votes
and we
combine them with whatever operator it
is that does addition under the covers
of encryption and we can produce an
encrypted tally
and in most cases
um
that operation and in the case i'm going
to be talking about is actual just
simple multiplication
if we multiply together these encrypted
values we get an encryption of the sum
and by using that we can encrypt
all the votes
homomorphically tally them by just
multiplying them all together and we get
an encrypted tally
and then we can decrypt
just the tally
and show everybody that this is a
correct decryption of the tally and
people can see
yes okay this is
the correct decryption of that whole set
of
recorded votes without having to
individually decrypt each of those
recorded votes
okay so that's the basic idea of
homework italian
um
the
technique that we are using for this is
elgamal encryption i'm not going to go
through this but it's very standard
means of encryption very old very common
there's one trick that we're using it's
a little bit different because
with elgamal encryption if you do
pairwise or component-wise
multiplication of the
uh encrypted
components you get
um an encrypted product
um
said another way normally elgamal
encryption is multiplicatively
homomorphic we want something additively
homomorphic and what we do is just
change this to what's sometimes called
exponential elgamal and what we encrypt
is um the
data that we're trying to encrypt
but we have that in the exponent
we raise a fixed value to
that data power
so the difference is this you know g to
the m instead of m which was back there
and by doing that this changes it so
that if we multiply components now we
effectively add the exponents and get an
additively homomorphic encryption
function
okay
so elgamal encryption has a large number
of advantages
one is that it's what's used today for
the vast majority of all encrypted web
traffic um and most traffic now is
encrypted so it's very very common very
well known we have a lot of confidence
in the security of elgamal we're not
doing something exotic and it's actually
basically just
um the original diffie-hellman key
exchange that started public key
cryptography in 1976 these even predates
the rsa encryption algorithm
so it's very old very well studied it
provides
a natural randomization it's important
that the encryption is randomized
because you wouldn't want
it my encrypted vote and your encrypted
vote to be the same if our votes are the
same because then we could tell that the
votes were the same we want every
encryption to be different even if it's
an encryption of the same thing we need
to randomize the encryption and algomal
does that very naturally and very easily
although that can be done with other
cryptosystems it can be a little bit
more awkward um it can be used as i just
described to get an additive
homomorphism
it also supports
split key and shared encryption it's
very easy
for
multiple people to each generate an
elgamal encryption key
and combine them into one elgamal
public encryption key that can be used
to encrypt so that um
it requires all or a threshold subset of
the
the key holders to be able to work
together to decrypt and you want that in
an election because if
votes are encrypted you don't want one
person to have the key and be able to
decrypt them all you want to split that
power among a canvassing board or some
set of
entities in opposition that will only
work together under the appropriate
circumstances to do tallying and other
other such things
we also want to be able to do certain
zero knowledge proofs of the properties
and uh elgamal encryption is very good
at that there are some very simple zero
knowledge proofs that are well known
that can work that to prove that ballots
are well-formed for instance i'll talk
about that a little bit more in a bit
and it's extremely efficient um
as i said it's used for most web traffic
today so there's no issue with it being
too slow and cumbersome
okay that's the first question um i
promised to answer but i have to get
back to the second question
we know what to do once the votes have
been encrypted but how is it that voters
are supposed to turn their preferences
into votes
right we're talking about human beings
as voters how do they encrypt
well we don't want them to encrypt with
their own devices
because their own devices could be
compromised
um but if we're going to say okay you
come in you vote in person using a
dedicated
device used by
the election system by the election
offices
then why is it that i as a voter should
have any confidence that my selections
have been accurately encrypted so we
need to find some way to engage humans
in some sort of interactive process
so that they can if they want check to
see that their votes are correctly
captured and encrypted so how is it that
humans can do reasonable encryption
it turns out that there are ways of
not actually doing the encryption but
checking the encryption that aren't hard
at all
and the trick is basically one of
being able to believe something even if
you haven't seen it in great detail and
i'm going to demonstrate this as a card
trick but this would be done with with
votes instead suppose i have a bunch of
cards and i want to convince you
that
um that
these cards are all red okay so i make a
claim all the cards below are read
and now i'll let you
challenge me i'll let you check mate and
i'll let you start turning over cards
and you can turn over that one and maybe
you'll choose that one next and maybe
that one next maybe that one next
and every time you turned over a card it
was red and you chose what which card to
turn over
well at this point there's still one
card left that hasn't been turned over
but you now have some reason to believe
that this remaining card is red
because you got to choose which cards
stayed uncovered and anytime you you
turned over a card it was red
so the only way that that card might be
black would be if somehow i was able to
guess in advance what you were going to
do and which cards you were going to
turn over
furthermore this card is a card that you
haven't seen
so you have developed some belief that
this card is red
even though
you haven't turned it over you don't
know what it is you don't know even
though you know that it's red or you
believe it's red you have no idea
whether it's a diamond or a heart you
don't know what its rank is
so you have no way once once this
process is done
of
going
away
and convincing anybody that that card is
read you believe the card is read
because you engage in this process
but you have no way of showing anybody
what your vote was if that card
represents your vote you have good
reason to believe it's red but it's
non-transferable even though you now
believe it's red you there's nothing you
can do to go and convince somebody else
after the fact that that card is read so
that card could represent your vote you
could think of yourself as writing your
name on that card and it becomes your
vote
okay
so now let's turn this more a little bit
to voting suppose i as a voter have said
i want to vote for adams and the device
says okay here are a bunch of votes for
atoms um they're all encrypted and the
voter can say okay i'm going to take
that fourth one
and say device decrypt
reveal the keys decrypt the other ones
now
voters do not have to do decryption or
check decryption or do anything with
numbers in practice this is just getting
a little bit closer to what would
actually happen and then
this decryption could be done to show
voters that um the the
votes that they asked to be revealed are
all for adams
therefore again they have reason to
believe that this last one is for adams
now in practice we wouldn't ask voters
to do anything like this the only thing
we need to do in practice is to give
voters an opportunity to open a ballot
whenever they want
during the process of
creating a vote
and casting a vote once the vote is cast
it's locked but they can say okay here's
the vote i want
create an encrypted version of that for
me of course we wouldn't use encryption
as the term and talking to voters but we
would give voters effectively a
confirmation
a commitment to that vote the encryption
of that vote and then give the voters
the ability to either cast it or
choose to spoil it and spoiling it will
cause it to be opened
now
not every voter needs to do this even if
just a very small fraction of voters
spoil even just a single ballot
you get very high integrity statistics
are on our side here for instance if a
hundred voters in a national election
each spoil one single ballot
um then
any alteration of
one percent or more of the votes in the
entire election would be um likely to be
detected would probably be detected as
long as this is reasonably random nobody
knows which voters might spoil a ballot
ahead of time or we could turn that up a
little bit and imagine
one percent
of voters in a in an election spoiling
ballots not everybody not close to
everybody just a tiny fraction just one
percent that's enough to get the
confidence in an election down to within
100 votes
in an election a national election which
might have you know well over 100
million votes being able to be accurate
within 100 votes
has a very strong capability
and it doesn't take much just a small
fraction of voters need to
do this spoiling and checking in order
to achieve that
so what does an election look like in
practice well when it's done there will
be a record
you will have all the ballots that have
been cast
you'll have the totals together with the
proof you'll have all the spoiled
ballots
and
decryptions of all the spoiled ballots
so if i am a diligent voter i might
spoil a ballot and then look at the
the website afterwards and and check my
spoiled ballot and see that it decrypted
the way i expected it to i still don't
have to decrypt
um i just
would be able to look and see okay
this supposedly was decrypted
the way that
i uh
i
expected
and the other things that would be there
would be
the proofs
which
you might remember done with homomorphic
tallying but of course
we get the
the sum effectively by taking the
product of these votes and then we can
keep everything else encrypted
and then just
release
a key to show that this has been
decrypted properly
so
all these things are easily checkable
anybody can write some sort of a
verification tool that will go through
and check all of these things and make
sure that everything on the website is
correct so voters don't have to be
burdened with doing any uh encryptions
or decryptions of any kind they can just
look at the website
and see that their votes are there
recorded the way they expected their
cast if they presumably they cast
one ballot each and make sure that the
cast ballot is part of the record and if
they spoiled any ballots they make sure
the spoiled ballots are part of the
record and that they are shown as having
decrypted the way that they expect
okay
so this leaves a very nice task that's
completely separate from what a voter
would be likely to do which is writing a
verifier they'll go through the election
record and there are a lot of things
that a verifier has to be able to do the
verification app would verify that all
of the encrypted ballots are correctly
combined to form the encrypted tallies
to verify that the encrypted tally is
correctly decrypted to verify that all
the spoiled ballots are correctly
decrypted
and to verify that each encrypted ballot
is well formed
meaning that it really is just
encryptions of zeros and ones and this
is where most of the zero knowledge
groups come in
it's all possible i've worked with
students at several places and had them
write election verifiers of this sort
it's a wonderful little project i'll
talk about that a little bit more in a
bit but first i just want to give you a
sense of what this looks like to a voter
um a verifiable election system to a
voter can look exactly like a current
system with one small addition and that
is we would give the voter a receipt of
some sort a confirmation code basically
which looks like here is
not your vote this doesn't show how you
voted but this is the encrypted vote or
a hash of your encrypted vote some
commitment to your encrypted vote so you
can take this home and check on the
website yep
my encrypted vote is there
and you can also have one of these for
every time you spoil the ballot and say
yep my spoiled ballot is there and that
looks correct that's the only difference
now i've learned in my years of working
in this subject that i can give voters
options i can give them something like
this and give them the option to do
extra but i can't get in their way and
force them to do anything more so
voters can
take these receipts
check that their votes have been
properly recorded
and we found that when this is done a
good percentage
maybe 30 percent of voters will do this
most voters will throw their receipts
away they'll look at this and say what
is this i don't want to throw it away
that's fine we don't need every voter to
check any voter who wants to can check
that's the thing we're achieving
voters could also write their own
election verifiers if they want to
um
where if few probably will
but it's not that hard it's a nice class
project or they could download verifiers
from sources of their choice and run
them
on any particular election so from their
favorite you know source from their um
their you know
maybe my niece just took a computer
science class where she wrote an
election verifier great i'll take that
and i'll run that on my election and see
or maybe my candidate um has a verifier
posted that i can do
or i could as a voter just believe the
verifications done by political parties
or
various interest groups or observers
um
in any
third party can run their own verifier
and check or i can do what most people
still do today is just accept the
results i don't have to do any of these
things it's a capability it's not a
requirement
okay so where are we with these
technologies well i'll quickly mention
that there have been some real world
deployments helios is
a system that
uses this technology
in an entirely web-based form
entirely online
it's been used for
many different applications it was used
to elect
the president of uc levane in belgium
not the student body president the
actual president of the university it's
been used
by princeton university for student
government elections various
professional societies it's a convenient
tool
for a web-based forum
i wouldn't recommend this for public
elections but for
smaller society elections things like
that i think um that that's a very good
approach
uh there's a system called scantegrity
that was used about a decade ago in
municipal elections in takoma park
maryland um it had some some very
interesting tricks
to it
but what i'm going to be talking about
mostly now for the last few minutes of
this presentation is election guard this
is something that microsoft has put
together it's a free
open source toolkit it's not an entire
election system but it's a toolkit that
enables
others to take these tools and build
them into
other systems touch screen systems
optical scanners vote by mail systems
and even internet voting if you want to
do that although again i'm not
recommending that for public elections
um
this is something that microsoft is
making available free it's sort of a
corporate responsibility because we have
the expertise to do this
and it is very technical and
uh frankly uh you know current election
vendors
are not very well resourced in the us
and don't have um the the skills to be
able to do something like this but they
can take
what we provide and build it into their
systems now just because we build it
doesn't mean you have to trust us either
we the the idea of this end-to-end
verifiability is you don't have to trust
anybody including microsoft um in in
using this and you can check for
yourself
so we've had various partners that we've
been working with um and various um
jurisdictions
that have been very interested in using
this um to
build election guard to start
making it available
in particular it got its first
public
use
in
fulton wisconsin about 18 months ago
this was going to be the first of many
uses at the time but
note the date february 2020 something
started to happen in march 2020 things
kind of shut down
and a lot of election administrators we
were talking to who were very interested
in trying things and innovating turned
from the a posture of innovation to a
posture of hanging on by their
fingernails and just trying to make sure
our elections happened at all
that year so we didn't get many
opportunities to do
pilots
but we are starting that up again and
that is starting to happen i did get a
lot of coverage of the time
various sources cnn had some nice
coverage usa today i i particularly like
cnet's claim about this that um
this could be the most important product
for microsoft in 2020 if it works yes it
works it really does work
another use um in the november 2020
elections was used in a very different
form
um for
preserving privacy in a post-election
risk limiting audit that happened after
the november 2020 elections it was done
in one county in california
went very well
another place that was used this may be
somewhat surprising is
in the u.s house of representatives
democratic caucus we of course made this
available to both house and senate and
all the caucuses but the
most elections
in
congress are open ballot
but the elections for the leadership are
secret ballot even within the the
of the caucus um and they didn't want to
meet in person so we had another partner
uh markup in this case um who we worked
with to build an app um for um use in
this context and this was used to elect
the speaker and the whip and uh majority
leader and other offices uh went very
well um this is not a fully public
election it was very constrained so we
we felt comfortable with this
application but it was um you know
something that you know we're proud of
it haven't been done
um and just a few months ago we
announced a partnership with one of the
major election vendors in the us heart
and your civic
and they will be integrating this
technology into their premier line of
optical scanners so
maybe in a few years coming to
a
voting system near you um we're we're
certainly talking to other vendors as
well we hope it will become ubiquitous
um but in particular um
hart is doing this and we're expecting
to see some pilots um early next year
just a couple of things about election
guard we've
worked hard to make it very clean
very simple ai try to make it hard to
misuse
and
my key design criteria in a lot of the
choices was trying to make the writing
of election verifiers as easy as
possible because this is something we
want many people to do
we want
independent verification a microsoft
verifier on microsoft election guard
isn't so useful we want you and your
students and others to write verifiers
to check elections that have used this
technology
so
writing an election verifier is a great
class opportunity it's a great
independent study project
or even a in-class assignment
and
please feel free to contact me if you
want to learn more
also everything is open source so we
welcome contributions we'd be very happy
to um have uh work done there's a lot
that's being built out and extended and
the more the merrier this is a project
that we'd like to have many many people
be part of
in improving election confidence
some references
election guard dot vote is the main site
and all the open source stuff is on
github at github.com microsoft election
guard
um and
um that's going to wrap things up um
i thank you for your time and attention
for those of you in the pacific time
zone um i will be uh sticking around a
little bit after the the talk
immediately after this is going to be uh
by dan walk of rice university he's
going to be talking about how he's
developed
this technology as a teaching tool and
built a small unit for a security class
that uses this technology so please i
encourage you to stay around for that
and then immediately afterwards for
those in the pacific time zone both dan
and i will be available for questions
and we'd be happy to
answer any questions that you might have
so thank you for joining us and i hope
to hear from you soon you can contact me
personally at benilo with microsoft.com
thank you again
hello everybody and welcome back to the
microsoft research summit 2021
my name is dan walak i'm a professor at
rice university and today i'm going to
be telling you about some work i'm doing
in collaboration with microsoft on a
system called election guard
and where it is and where it's going
and first i'm going to make sure i click
in the right window so that way my
slides work so my research is in the
space of electronic voting system
security that has meant finding
vulnerabilities in older systems as well
as designing processes procedures and
designs for new systems that generally
involve printed paper ballots
now
i have been working in this area on and
off for almost 20 years and the more i
learn about it the harder i realize it
is to build secure usable reliable
well-engineered voting systems
and it's important to also learn lessons
from other people who have had troubles
this is an example where swiss post the
the post office of switzerland
uh commissioned a company to build for
them a fancy cryptographic online voting
system
and it turned out to have really
significant bugs
that would allow
somebody to create forged proofs so the
the proof is claiming that some property
is true of an encrypted value and turns
out you can forge the proofs that's
really bad in the end to swiss post's
credit they pulled the the trial that
they were doing and said well we need to
get back and really think about what
we're doing so with that as a backdrop
microsoft is now also working in this
space
so the talk before me you heard from
josh benilo who did a lot of the design
work all of the design work behind
election guard
and
microsoft's goal was to produce an open
source software development kit that
would enable other vendors and companies
to build secure electronic voting
machines using state-of-the-art
cryptography
and
would take a lot of the
design and engineering
research and development risk out of it
rather than having to figure out how to
do it yourself or you might get it wrong
we're going to have
really good people designing something
right and getting it right from the
beginning and that's what election guard
was meant to be
the original implementation
was again designed by josh benello and
implemented at galwa research in
portland oregon
they built a formal model
that allowed them just to explore the
design and make sure it fit together
they built a voting machine client that
was in c
and they built a verifier in rust
that c code was then embedded alongside
a ballot marking device that was done by
a not-for-profit called voting
votingworks and that was piloted in an
election in early to 2020 in fulton
wisconsin
i hope i got that pointing at the
correct part of the map it's it's um
it was a very small pilot but
nonetheless an important opportunity to
validate that all of these things work
now
when i was getting engaged in the
project was in 2020
that
um
things were in motion there were many
changes to the spec there was a new
contractor working on it inferno red
and i was on sabbatical from rice
working with voting works and the
project that i was going to build was an
election auditing
technique which i'll tell you about in a
couple slides but i needed all the same
cryptographic primitives i needed all
the machinery that
was in election guard the voting machine
i needed in the thing that we were
building an election auditing tool and i
didn't want to start from scratch who
does
so
there was a collect very quickly i'm in
meetings with microsoft people and
others
and there was a collective decision that
there we were going to start over
and it was going to be in python and
there would be a full featured python
reference implementation where
everything is there everything works
everything is tested etc
and then there would be offshoot
implementations that would implement
subsets of the reference implementation
that would be useful for specific use
cases where maybe you couldn't fit
python
but python was the go going to be the
reference implementation
and at the time other people were busy
and i needed it so i started working on
it and later on handed it off to the
team at inferno red
so where do we stand today which is a
year and a half after that
well now we have really extensive unit
tests this code is not what i would call
formally verified
but it is
based on some battle-hardened math with
tests that try lots and lots of inputs
looking for counter examples
and what that means is
even though these tests are not the same
thing as formal verification nonetheless
they've helped us find bugs in the spec
you know where there was like a typo and
an equation well then the tests didn't
pass
so that's all done also this is built in
modern python 3 with type annotations
which means that we can type check it
and that means that a whole class of
runtime bugs that happen in dynamically
typed programming languages the none of
those bugs should manifest it manifest
themselves in the election guard
reference implementation the code is
pretty good stuff
it's written in a
mostly functional simplified subset of
python limited use of exceptions and by
doing this it's relatively easy to cut
and paste the python into some other
programming language that you prefer
because if you have functions and if you
have data structures then you can
implement
election guard by transliterating the
code from python to your favorite
programming language
and
from the beginning we knew that
parallelization was going to be an
important attribute and that but by
thinking about that at the start it
really helped us later on when we needed
to get scalable performance that's also
coming up in a future slide
not only do we need to have all of the
cryptographic machinery but we need to
have data structures that represent what
is an election what is a contest what is
a candidate well how many candidates are
in a contest
is that a contest where you can vote for
one event or k event or something else
so election guard has a full suite of
data structures to represent elections
contests ballots encrypted ballots and
many other related things all built
around some data structures that were
designed at the national institute of
standards and technologies for precisely
this sort of thing
and that means that we can serialize
these python data structures out to json
and then now we have an interchange
format that we can have be portable from
python to other implementations
so in order to tell you about the thing
that i built
i have to first have a brief digression
and i need to tell you a little bit
about something called a risk limiting
audit
so
this is a process that happens after an
election is over
and what we're trying to do
is to look at hand marked paper ballots
and electronic tallies of those paper
ballots
and
we're worried that the computer that
does the electronic tallying might be
mistaken or perhaps tampered or hacked
so computers can count really fast but
we're worried about their security
physical paper is very secure
but it's very slow it requires human
beings to move it around
so what we want
is a statistical sampling methodology
that lets us roll dice
to pick out which ballots we're going to
look at to touch just a small number of
ballots and match them up one to one
with the electronic version and that
helps us gain confidence that any error
in the electronic tabulation
is too small to change the winner
so that's the risk that we're trying to
limit in a risk limiting audit we're
trying to limit the risk of having the
wrong winner of an election
this is a statistical method that was
designed about a decade ago
by a professor in the stats department
at uc berkeley and it's growing in use
across the country
so what we're doing is that in a real
world physical process to mitigate
against the risks of software that
either has bugs or is tampered
so
how can we use some of this
cryptographic machinery that's in
election guard to improve a risk
limiting audit which is a physical
real-world process
so first i have to tell you about one
little corner case about risk-limiting
audits
which is that the number of ballots
you're supposed to look at is a function
of the margin of victory if the margin
of victory in an election gets really
small you need to look at more ballots
because the margin of error or your
tolerance your risk for error is much
smaller without changing who won when
you have a small margin of victory
so
how do we
how do we compute that
well
we ask the computer to tell us the
margin of victory what if that's the
very computer that we're trying to audit
what if it's lying
so
cryptography to the rescue
if we can encrypt the entire election
encrypt all the ballots and post those
encrypted ballots online prior to the
start of the risk limiting audit
then
[Music]
that means that
any
funny business where there might have
been
whether the machine that's doing the
tallying might have been trying to
manipulate the outcome
once it's committed to all those
encrypted ballots it can't take them
back
and
from the encrypted ballots using all the
same mathematics of election guard any
independent observer can verify
that the this set of encrypted ballots
implies this margin of victory
and by taking that out of the hands of
the
vote tallying computers we improve the
security of the risk limiting audit
these ideas were first explored in a
research paper only in 2019
so
here i am one year after the publication
of this paper trying to implement this
idea
but before i can implement the idea i
have to make election guard go fast
because here are some rough numbers
take a big city the size of houston
texas
in a major national election we could
easily have 1.2 million ballots
and pretend that those all went through
a high speed paper scanner
and now i have a comma separated value
file with 1.2 million rows and that's my
input that's where i'm starting a
computation
i need to encrypt each of those and
every ballot by the way will generate
about a megabyte of ciphertext
so now i need to generate a terabyte of
data
and
if i was running on my single on a
single core of my desktop it would take
six seconds per ballot times 1.2 million
ballots it's not going to happen
so we need to go at 160 ballots per
second in order to encrypt the election
in about two hours
the only way we're going to do that is
to throw somewhere north of a thousand
cpu cores at the problem
so one of the nice parts about election
guard is all of the core abstractions
here is a plain text ballot encrypted
can be easily parallelized here are a
million ballots encrypt them
independently
so
when you look at the problem that way
this maps very very well to a map reduce
style computation where you're mapping
from plain text ballots to encrypted
ballots and then your the reduction is
where you are doing
a homomorphic tally of encrypted ballots
you can add ciphertexts without
decrypting them first
we can do this homomorphic tally that
looks like the reduction part of a
mapreduce computation
so
this is a style of paralyzing programs
that we have been familiar with since
the early 2000s it's well understood
and it works really well at the end now
we have a thousand machines
perhaps on amazon ec2 perhaps on
microsoft azure writing out to
some kind of parallel file storage
system like amazon s3 or azure blob
storage
and these can be written concurrently
from thousands of separate computers and
at the very end the election official
just computes a merkle tree over all of
these files and publishes one root hash
so in fact this was what i wrote for my
sabbatical in the calendar year of 2020.
votingworks is a work from home company
so i was working from home for voting
works while i was on sabbatical then
covet happened and i continued working
from home
except suddenly i had housemates again
but
anyway
so this was this went from idea to pilot
implementation in less than a year
and so we did our pilot with the
election officials at inyo county
california which i've highlighted on the
map on the right
and you know
i engineered the system for 1.2 million
ballots and ran it with just shy of 10
000. so this happened fast like three
minutes flat to encrypt everything
and that was the world's first ever
verifiable risk limiting audit
yay trumpets fanfare it was pretty cool
and all the code is open source you can
download it all today
so the next thing i want to talk about
marching along with my talk is a more
recent thing that i built
i was talking to
some people at microsoft and i said
wouldn't it be cool if we could use
election guard
to help teach these concepts of
encryption and whatnot
to
computer science students at
universities
and so i spent a month this summer in
building this
the goal is to have a two or three week
long assignment this could fit into a
cryptography class this could fit into a
computer security class that might have
a cryptography module of some sort
and
the election guard
building election guard
teaches you a lot of the pieces and
parts of how many other cryptographic
systems work
so it seems like a good place to begin
you know if you want to understand more
sophisticated hash data structures
election guard uses simple ones if you
want to understand more sophisticated
zero knowledge proofs election guard
uses simpler ones it's a good place to
begin
so
what did i what did i build i built two
separate implementations of exactly the
same thing so these are called election
guard edu kotlin and python implemented
respectively in the programming
languages kotlin and python
and there's complete feature parity all
the functions have the same names all
the functions do the same things
and
the idea is that all the code is there
but there are holes there are functions
that say to do
they're not done yet and it's up to the
student to fill in those blanks
and
i used all of the original election
guard unit tests as an auto grader just
assigned points to them to make sure
that students implement the functions
that cause the tests to pass
here's the assignment
in week one
they implement a variety of let's call
them missing functions
so one is using elgamal
in a mode where you have multiple
trustees who combine their public keys
together to create a shared public key
where somebody can encrypt a message for
the shared key and then all of those
trustees must work together to decrypt
that message
we're using so partial decryption and
then combination
a fairly sophisticated topic although
the elgamal math is just a bunch of
multiplies it's very simple
so that's just one of these missing
functions that students have to put
together
likewise they use encryption primitives
including the algomall encryption and
sean peterson uh
non-interactive zero knowledge proofs
to encrypt an individual counter you
know a a ballot is a set of races a race
is a set of candidates and for each
candidate there is a little counter
that's a zero or a one so they implement
that in the first week as well as
i have them implement a test where if
you tamper with the cipher text then the
john peterson proof breaks
but that's a property that you would
expect to be true
they they're going to verify that
property
in week two the students put it all
together for general purpose
vote for any k out of n candidate style
elections
and so election guard has a particular
spec for how you're supposed to encrypt
this how you're supposed to use
placeholders what kinds of properties
you're approving what kinds of
properties you're checking
so week one the students are getting
used to the library week two they're
implementing the real deal for how you
encrypt a ballot
and they're also doing some performance
measurement
since performance matters students
should have to think about and measure
some performance
i also wrote up an optional week three
where
the way
election guard does its modular
exponentiation which is the core
primitive inside elgamal the core
primitive inside john peterson proofs
oftentimes you have the same
value either a generator or a public key
that's
a value being used as the base and then
taken to some modular exponent
there are some really simple performance
optimizations you can do where you do
some pre-computation in advance and then
you can replace that modular
exponentiation with a series of lookups
and multiplies
so the students as an optional third
week exercise could implement that
here's a fun thing i did that any
student using this as an exercise will
hopefully appreciate
so there's some code on the right that
hopefully is very simple we start with a
random key pair
and we use the key pair to encrypt the
number three and then we decrypt the
number we decrypt that cipher text using
the key pair and we get back out the
plain text so we can see that here it is
kotlin telling us that the plain text is
three again
but if i say print the ciphertext
i get this big long mess of digits
and if some of the units tests don't
pass a student will look at a 4 000 bit
number and not really know where to
begin
to debug it and that's not
fun if you're a student it's also not
fun if you are a professor on sabbatical
trying to do the very same thing
so for the election guard edu code base
i added symbolic formulas whenever you
take two numbers and multiply them or
exponentiate them or add them or do
whatever you do you are building a
symbolic expression as you go
so
if i look at that thing where i say show
me the formula for the pad portion of
the ciphertext
you know that's
an infix expression that's just your g
to the r for some random value r
if i look at that part
well it looks the same as before but i
know where that came from i know that
that's actually the public key there's
actually a way inside the library to
change what the label is so i could i
could change this formula to replace it
with you know there's just the string
public dash key we could do this in a
bunch of ways but
this i can then look at this whole thing
and say oh right that looks like g cubed
that's the the part on the top line and
then the pot the part on the bottom line
looks like g to the a to the r
i mean if you're not a lisp programmer
then prefix notation like this is not
the world's easiest thing to read
but i promise you if you were a student
trying to debug this code this will make
your life much much easier
so
the last thing i wanted to mention is
that this is built to be an assignment
working with github classroom and using
github actions to run the autograder so
every time a student does a git commit
get push the auto grader runs
as a push action inside the github cloud
somewhere
so the way that works is that it's
simply the unit tests are mapped to
points
and the auto grader just runs the unit
tests and the signs points to them and
prints at the bottom so here we see our
our students starting off with 0 out of
19 points and it says the names of all
the unit tests that have failed when
they eventually get to the full
set of points then the build will pass
as well and when they look at their
github commit history they'll see red
x's up until the point where they got
the build working and then they'll see a
green check mark
so
this is great for the students
because they're not reliant on
on their personal computer if something
goes wrong
if their computer is configured in a
weird way
and if you've ever taught a large class
you know that there's always one or two
students who have computers that
somehow got into a strange state
now the student will have confidence
that when they push the code and the
tests pass on the server that they're
good they didn't forget anything there's
nothing weird about their computer if it
works on the server it works
from a grader's perspective this is also
great because now the graders don't need
to download the code the grader just
looks at what's on github
including the the code that's submitted
and the unit tests that have passed or
failed
and this really speeds up the effort for
your lab assistants and teaching
assistants
to assign grades to students using this
material
all right so that's all available if you
want to use it you email me and say hi
dan i would love to teach with your
materials
and then i will give you access to two
private repositories that have uh two
branches here's the branch that you hand
out to the students and here's the
branch that has a reference
implementation where all the tests pass
so that way you can you know have
something to look at something to see
how it's all supposed to fit together
for yourself
the python and kotlin code is absolutely
equivalent uh the the assignment spec is
one latex file that just has little if
defs inside of it so it can generate a
handout for python and a handout for
for kotlin exactly the same
so it's just a matter of if yours if you
think that your students have had good
python skills then use the python
version of the assignment if you think
your students know kotlin then use the
collin version if your students know
java kotlin is probably easier to pick
up than python
it's up to you but i'm giving you two
completely separate implementations that
work exactly the same way
if you're not sure if you want to learn
more
this url below will give you access to a
public repository where you can see my
slide deck that introduces modern
cryptography
for certain definitions of modern that
other people might disagree with
but you know enough cryptography to be
able to do the assignment as well as
some handout pdfs so you can see what it
looks like from a student's perspective
all right in the last couple of minutes
left i want to mention that
election guard implementations are
happening completely outside of
microsoft outside of me outside of
inferno red
so there are two open source ones that
i've found so far one was built by a
fellow named john karen and he
re-implemented it from python into java
another fellow alex mason built it in
haskell
i think it's this this is sort of proof
that we kept the code simple enough that
people could look at it and
transliterate it to their favorite
programming language
so
if you are uh
an aficionado of haskell you can use
that
i here's a recent paper that that i was
thrilled to see published
so you know i said that we haven't done
any machine check proofs but somebody
else did
on their own so here we have three
authors who put in a bunch of effort and
did a
a machine checked proof of universal
verifiability what's that it's one of
many properties that you might want from
an election system
and so they implemented this in a formal
way which i think is fantastic good
stuff
this is further evidence that election
guard is becoming
a platform a platform for building other
applications a platform for launching
other research efforts
so in my final slide for today i'm going
to tell you a little bit about some
ongoing work
microsoft itself has partnered with
heart inner civic which is one of the
three big u.s based election equipment
providers
um there isn't much more that's
available in public right now
but
i really look forward to seeing what
comes out of this
i think
this is a test about whether election
guard really is the right level of
abstraction for a company to adopt
without
having to
have a deep level of technical
sophistication for how this sort of
election related cryptography works
i hope that this goes well
meanwhile at rice i happen to be running
a senior level design class this
semester and i have a team of six
students working on
integrating election guard with a vote
by mail style system the idea being that
there would be an in-browser experience
to pick who you're voting for and it
would generate a printed ballot that
would have some cryptographic add-ons at
the bottom but would otherwise be a
completely ordinary paper ballot
this is work in progress and it's going
to involve making a typescript
re-implementation
of election guard which again should be
fairly straightforward and useful to
have around
and the last thing is that i'm currently
working with both josh benello at
microsoft research and olivier pereira
at
university catholique levan de nov in
belgium
and
we are going back and forth with ideas
for how to make election guard go faster
in particular how to make the
cryptography go faster
turns out when you're doing the same
thing over and over again there are lots
of opportunities for performance
enhancements
so that's what we're working on
i'd like to thank you all very much for
coming to my talk
and
um everybody have a great day thank you
very much
enjoyed the uh recorded presentations
that that just aired uh dan wallach and
i are here live um josh benello and um
we're hoping to be able to take any
questions that you might have here live
dan
so i'm dan wallach and thank you again
for having me here at the microsoft
research summit again we are live to
take your questions and i'm going to
start off by asking josh about a
question from the chat during the talk
which is that we've chosen to use
elgamal cryptography which is a classic
from the early 80s along with much of my
favorite music
and
the these days we're worried about
post quantum we're worried about
computers that might be able to
break
the public key cryptography that's used
in elgamal and other crypto systems
so
what would it take to
re-engineer election guard to use a
post-quantum crypto system what would be
the costs what would would it be in
terms of size of ballot performance and
so forth
thanks dan you know and we we considered
this quite a lot um
during the the development of of
election garden the truth is
that post quantum
algorithms are just not yet up to the
the requirements that we have we have
many um challenges that we've had to
overcome
and we are
stuck with the
uh
the current class of algorithms now for
a variety of reasons
um first of all um performance um
the the quantum resistant algorithms
that are just being developed now
have
huge issues with performance in one
dimension or another um either they're
very slow they have enormously large
keys
enormously large cipher text
many many things
that would make
a
a post-quantum solution just impractical
for election guard today
another issue is that we've tried very
hard to make
um
election guard
very much
easily accessible
to have good
understandability by anybody who's
writing a verifier so we could make
things a little bit more performant by
using elliptic key cryptography but
instead we're using
simple integer algorithms we're using
4096 bid elgamal which is
much larger than you would normally see
but that's giving us a good margin of
error
while keeping things easily
understandable and we have
i mentioned um in the talk
several of the advantages of elgamal
being very good for split key being very
good for having zero knowledge proofs of
the capabilities those things just
aren't there yet with the post quantum
algorithms that exist so
if
in
several years we get to a point where we
might want to do
a post-quantum version of election guard
or you might want to do it because it's
all open source after all
feel free please
then we'll cross that bridge when we
come to it
right now the threat is pretty minimal
because
if
somebody 20 years from now actually came
up with a a suitable quantum computer
that could break 40 96-bit encryption
and once they got tired of applying that
to steal all the bitcoin in the world
and the other things that they might do
with it and they turned it to an
election record from 20 years earlier
what they would get is here are a bunch
of clear text votes but they still
wouldn't be able to see who it is that
cast those votes and the only link would
be
something of the sort of if i had saved
my verification code from 20 years ago
and somebody could look at that code
they could associate that in the record
and say ah that code that 20 year old
code is associated with that vote and
that
it's a threat but i think it's a threat
that we can manage so i'm not that
worried about that
and when you talk to the political
scientists they say tell me your address
and i'll tell you how you vote the
the the homogeneity of of neighborhoods
tells you with high probability how
anybody who lives in those neighborhoods
vote so you actually have
the the the sophistication of the
cryptography is far greater than the
sophistication of how we self-sort
ourselves into where we choose to live
and work
indeed
so again we encourage people to
type any
questions you may have in the chat um
i'm
not seeing any others yet but uh please
um feel free ah
so while we're waiting let me throw a
question at you josh
please this is like i have my own
personal cryptographer i can ask him
anything i want what a great opportunity
so we hear a lot about blockchain
internet voting and often blockchain
internet voting and sometimes that's
pronounced mobile voting because if it's
on your phone that's somehow different
from in your web browser
how are the technologies that were using
an election guard or related
technologies from the blockchain
community what problems do they solve
and what problems do they not solve like
what are the risks or benefits or
dangers of blockchain internet voting
well because i'm about to say some very
negative things i should
qualify this by saying i'm not
anti-blockchain
blockchains are okay they do interesting
things
they should do those interesting things
as far away from elections as possible
i
was quoted by the associated press a few
years ago
saying that
anyone promoting blockchain elections
either doesn't understand blockchains
doesn't understand elections or is being
dishonest
and i stand by that quote blockchains
don't solve any of the real problems
associated with internet voting and
there are some real problems associated
with internet voting and in fact the use
of blockchains just creates new problems
and makes things harder um so i'm not
going to go into it in in great gory
detail but there are so many problems
introduced by blockchains and they just
excuse me don't solve any of the real
problems they don't sell for instance
the client malware problem
if i'm voting over the internet and
there's malware on my device that flips
my vote
um then
that's before it ever touches a
blockchain uh my vote has changed now
end-to-end verifiability this technology
can be used to make it possible for me
to see that my vote has been flipped and
if i check it i can see that and i can
then go somewhere else and correct it
because there's malware obviously
malware on my device that did it i could
go from go to another place so i can
address these issues but um they still
create a lot of challenges and the the
short of this is that although there are
many people who would really love to do
internet voting and many reasons why
people seem to want to do internet
voting
even though it doesn't seem to have the
desired effect on turnout that one might
expect it doesn't have
people suggest that if we have internet
voting then we'll have a tremendous
increase in voter turnout the cases
where it's been available that just
doesn't seem to be the case um but
even you know with with all those things
we don't seem to be ready to do
responsible internet voting in public
elections today there are narrow
contexts where internet voting can make
sense uh certainly for things like
professional societies or student body
elections things which are
a little bit less sensitive
it's a very good use of the technology
uh and very good use of intent
verifiability but for
general public elections today
the general consensus is that we're not
quite ready so i think an interesting
related
case is that members of the us military
who are serving abroad
will and i'm not making this up fax
their ballots back
and
if the competition is can you do
something better than a fax machine
where an election official or where
sorry where a pentagon official
somewhere in washington dc
receives tens of thousands of faxes and
then sen
transcribes them back onto ballots and
then mails those back
that's something we can probably do
better then
yeah i i agree with that um ironically
faxes used to be more secure than they
are today they used to go over at least
a a private dedicated line it's kind of
hard to tap a fax channel except faxes
today typically travel over the internet
and uh not over secure channels um in
fact um
what what we're seeing some of today is
people returning ballots by email as
email attachments
which is kind of the worst
that you could imagine here um and we
can certainly have better solutions than
that email attachments have sort of all
the temperability that you know one
might imagine and then you know even
beyond that
um
i've talked to local election officials
who say
i get email attachments as ballots and
i'm supposed to have my staff click on
these random attachments and open them
this is risking infecting their machines
so email is about the worst thing we can
do there are better things there's a
system called helios voting um that is
an internet version of end-to-end
verifiability was deployed about 10
years ago it's been used to cast
millions of votes and i think it's a
very good solution for
low coercion low risk elections like
student body elections like uh
professional societies it's been used a
lot there it's great for that i don't
think we're ready for it for internet
voting but um
for for public elections but
it's a lot better than email attachments
i'll certainly say that so i want to go
to a question from robert sim who asks
what's the your biggest challenge in
describing this technology to election
officials and what are the barriers to
adoption both josh and i have been
working on some version of this problem
for a long long time and in fact an
earlier collaboration where josh and i
were working together with an election
official in austin texas or the travis
county clerk's office
they got excited about this class of
technology as applied to voting in the
early 20 teens and pointed the finger at
us and said hey you
time to stop criticizing us and time to
get in the room and help
and we ended up designing a system
called star vote and for
boring bureaucratic reasons the the
procurement process didn't quite work
out an election guard is in many
respects that
idea resurrected and made better
and
so in some cases election officials get
this and come to us
in other cases yeah we have to sell this
to election officials and election
officials turns out are super chatty
with each other they have conferences
you know and pre-covered they traveled
all over the place to go see each other
and hang out
and that's how ideas spread in that
community
and i think that
one of the things that i like about the
election guard project is that by
microsoft partnering with election
equipment vendors that helps get these
technologies closer to election
officials where when their own vendor is
offering it as an option they might be
more willing to consider it
yeah yeah and robert
you've certainly hit on a a
an important issue here
one of the big challenges is what's uh
sometimes called arithmophobia
fear of of math um
i have spoken to election officials who
have said
this end-to-end verifiability you're
talking about it sounds really good the
idea of not having to trust me not
having to trust my my equipment vendors
not have to trust anybody that sounds
really good but you're now asking me and
my voters to trust math
and well i trust math even less
so i have heard this
but the real
important point that's worth making here
is that right now
with current election systems
you as a voter have no choice of who to
trust you basically have to trust your
local election official and by proxy you
have to trust the equipment that your
local election official has chosen to
employ and the
equipment vendor and there's a whole
chain of trust that you have no choice
in when you use end-to-end verifiable
technologies
then this means that you get to choose
who to trust
you can still trust your local election
officials if you want but you can
instead proxy your trust to your
favorite candidate or your favorite
media outlet or any place you want or
not proxy your trust at all and do the
checks on your own you have that choice
and that's a key difference and i expect
that most people are not going to rent a
cluster from amazon or azure and run a
giant computation that's not a thing
that most people are going to do
but your local newspaper legal women
voters those kinds of organizations can
and will do exactly this i was once
having a chat with that one of the tech
people for one of the large news wires
and i was describing in vague hand-wavy
terms how all this stuff works and i
said so
would you would your organization you
know spin up a cluster and run these
verification things and he got super
excited like oh we would totally do that
and that's an interesting opportunity
where a voter might take that receipt
thing that they get
we need we need a better word than
receipt because it isn't actually proof
of who you voted for but if if you take
that receipt scan it with your phone and
it gets uploaded into the cloud of legal
women voters democratic party republican
party local newspaper associated press
and in fact they can all share with each
other because they all know that
receipts are all good
each of those organizations can run the
verification process
and if they find a contradiction if they
find something that's wrong
then they might reach back out to you
and say hey josh you know that receipt
that you scanned do you still have that
and then things start to get really
interesting
yeah um we've actually tried um with
limited success in election guard to get
away from the the term receipt because
it's created some confusion and i see
there's a question in the chat that you
know that is talking about that
confusion the
verification code tracking code we might
call it that voters receive after voting
does not say how you voted think of it
like a ups code it's got a number on it
it's a tracking code but it doesn't by
itself say
what's in that delivery that you're
getting or what's in that ballot that
you have just cast it allows you to
track your ballot to make sure it hasn't
been changed and there is a process um
having to do with spoiling that i i
shouldn't use the card trick to
um show it's it's a somewhat subtle
process but that can be used so that you
can be convinced that the contents of
that ballot really do represent what
what your intentions what your
selections were when you voted
but
you
have no way
when you use one of these systems of
showing anybody how you voted this would
be a very dangerous thing it would make
it easy to sell your vote it would make
it easy for you to be coerced and we
want very much to avoid that so i want
to be as clear as i can in saying that
yes we are providing voters with
a tracking code that you could call a
receipt
but if you do call it a receipt please
understand that it does not say how you
voted and cannot be used to show anybody
else how you voted
so i think we've addressed that was
batul durak's question i'm sorry i
apologize if i don't pronounce your name
correctly but receipt freeness is this
very subtle but important property and
it's a property that we see going all
the way back to the invention of the
australian ballot which josh mentioned
in his slides that if you go to the way
elections worked before we had a secret
ballot
the fact that you voted for a candidate
was well known and enabled bribery and
coercion and so it's really important
and this is a lesson that we learned in
the late 1800s and in fact was central
to the women's suffrage movement
is that a secret ballot is essential
and a secret ballot needs to be
compelled in the sense that it should
not be possible for you to choose to
reveal how you voted to anyone and even
if you want to reveal how you voted you
still can't
that
idea is an idea that became
central to election administration
over a century ago
and
it's a lesson that we should not give up
so soon and so easily
yeah i i think that that's critical um
it's
um something that is
a challenge even in cryptography because
if you you look at some of the results
of cryptography over the past years you
see well you can compute any function
you want in a private and secure manner
great we have tools to do this they may
not be efficient but these tools exist
they're not good enough for elections
because those tools things like secure
multi-party computation and other very
powerful cryptographic primitives
still allow individuals to show what
their inputs are to the function
they don't meet this additional privacy
requirement of elections that not only
is the privacy of my data my input my
vote in this case protected um but i am
unable to show anybody else how i voted
even if i want it um that's a very high
standard and that and that's a challenge
uh to achieve but we really do need that
level of
privacy if you're a student of
american electoral history you might
note that there's a little bit of a blip
in
the
list of american presidents that the
number of presidents doesn't correspond
to the number of the president
um and that's because of exactly this
point
that
grover cleveland was the 22nd president
of the united states he was elected
first in
in 1888 and at that time
we still did not have the secret ballot
in the u.s
um in
um
he was uh
challenged by benjamin harrison and in
an election that was seen universally as
strife with
um
with vote buying with coercion of
various sorts benjamin harrison defeated
river cleveland and became the 23rd
president of the united states but
because of that experience the
australian ballot of the secret ballot
swept through the u.s state by state
before the 1892 election and in 1892
grover cleveland again faced benjamin
harrison and with the benefit of the
secret ballot grover cleveland beat
benjamin harrison and became president
again and therefore became the 24th
president of the united states even
though he'd already been the 22nd
president of the united states and
that's why we've got this funniness of
you know numbers not quite matching up
so
one of the things that seems interesting
about these cryptographic election
schemes
is that there are so many of them out
there so anybody who's looked at some of
the results from the the swiss post
cital
adventure
there were proofs that turned out to be
forgeable
there were there were a number of things
that i guess we could describe as
implementation flaws
so is that the sort of reasoning that
led you to go with just elgimal and sean
peterson
things that are classic simple easily
understood
like did you go out of your way to avoid
fancy high-tech stuff
and if you could let just a little bit
of high-tech stuff back in what would
you want
uh very much so um yes there have been
many efforts at um at better voting
systems over the years especially
internet voting systems and because of
recent experiences
many of the purveyors of internet voting
systems have said oh you know this
end-to-end verifiability seems like an
important thing we should have it
um unfortunately
they often don't understand it very well
some have been just sort of outright
dishonest about claiming they do it when
they don't
um some like the case that you just
mentioned here
um have have
genuine honest efforts to achieve it
but they haven't achieved it end-to-end
verifiability is not an easy tool to
build and the current election vendors
in the u.s especially
but around the world are focused on
other things they're not typically
cryptographic experts they're trying to
get their systems out the door and you
know they're they're doing a very good
job of what they're doing at times
but
they
they have limitations in what they can
do so that's
the genesis of election guard we have
the ability to make this technology
available and we have
gone to some effort to try to make sure
that it's done right it's done simply
it's done in a usable way and it's
really pretty simple for election
vendors to to use um the the approach is
basically from the point of view of an
election equipment vendor
what you have to do is install the code
and every time
you
get a vote whether you're getting it on
a scanner or a ballot marking device or
wherever it is that you're collecting
votes every time you collect a vote you
call election guard with the contents of
that vote an election guard takes care
of the encryption and all the necessary
aspects of packaging things up and then
just gives you back the verification
code to give back to the voter um so we
try to make it as simple as possible and
as
standard as possible as
much as possible avoiding complexities
there are things that we would like to
do to use some slightly fancier things
to make things more performant and
and often simpler for verification and
we're starting to go down that road
because performance is critical in many
of our applications so we're offering
some you know slightly more advanced
cryptographic techniques but still being
very careful not to go to the
bleeding edge
on many of these things we want to have
very high confidence that
this technology um is is right and we're
not going to introduce something that's
going to fail down the road now still
independent verifiers can check us
but we can still have nightmare
scenarios of elections just not
completing properly or other things if
we don't do this right so we very much
want to be very careful about this and
introduce things
deliberately
so
this is an interesting question from
etienne hugo who asks what would the
additional software and hardware look
like to ensure the system as a whole is
secure for example preventing or
minimizing injection of false votes into
the election guard software so i think
we could look at this as a trusted
computing base question
like what is the minimum set of things
we need to trust in order to have
confidence that the outcome of an
election guard election is correct
so
what like do we actually need any of the
election guard code itself or even any
of the computers that voters are
touching
are are we requiring that software to be
correct or are we adequately capturing
and mitigating if there is malware in a
voting machine or in a tabulator
yeah that is a great question so
the election guard code
um
does not have to be trusted we are very
insistent on this this is the point of
independent verification you don't have
to trust your local election
vendors or
election officials
or microsoft or election guard in any
way you can independently verify
that
the votes have been properly
cast they've been properly recorded
they've been probably counted that
things have been done properly there but
the question does include some some
important other aspects because there
are some assumptions
we are not getting at all involved in
the voter authentication processes
so we are relying strictly on whatever
the existing means are of making sure
that the voters who come in
are
eligible to vote and that only eligible
voters are casting votes and that they
they cast one vote each and things like
that the usual procedures of sign in
and
counting the number of
voters now a lot of the procedures can
work very well for instance the list of
people who voted an election in the u.s
is generally a matter of public record
and that list
can be counted and can should correspond
to the number of votes that are actually
cast and then people can use the
election guard technology to use their
verification codes to say well my vote
was one of those casts and everybody who
cast the vote can say my vote was one
cast i see who all the other voters are
and i know that they've had an
opportunity uh to to cast uh
their votes and check that their votes
have been cast
the example that i gave during the talk
actually went a step further and had a
name next to every single
encrypted vote that has been cast
i think that's a fine way to do things
i'd be happy to do it
that way
most election jurisdictions are very
uncomfortable with that and prefer to
say
we want that extra layer of indirection
and we want it to be that
you can see that your vote is on the
list but there's nobody who's going to
be able to look and say see your name
directly and which encrypted vote
is attached to you even though
that still provides
the protection as long as the encryption
lasts
it does
if we go back to the quantum resistance
question make it so that if 20 years
later somebody was able to open the
record if there are names associated
with those ballots then they could see
20 years later who voted how so it is
kind of nice to be able to say okay
we'll have this in direction there's a
list of voters and there's a list of
votes and we know that everybody can
check um the association but you can't
specifically check whose vote even
encrypted form corresponds to who
now there's one interesting twist on
this which is a question that's often
described as hand marked versus machine
marked paper ballots
and the gist of this is consider two
alternative voting systems no fancy
cryptography at all voting system one we
have human beings who mark paper by hand
and then it's machine scanned
version two you have a touch screen
computer of some sort and you select
your candidates and you hit print and
then it prints a ballot the printed
ballot the hand marked ballot look
exactly the same same bubbles in the
same places so that's the setup
so
in a world where
you have a computer assisting you in the
production of that paper ballot
sometimes called a ballot marking device
there's a concern that malware in the
computer might show you the human being
one thing while printing something
different
and you know even on a printed paper
ballot it might you might vote president
alice
and
it might print out president bob instead
of alice and that's something that
it can print a completely consistent
ballot it can compute the election guard
encryption in a consistent way it just
differs from the voter's intent this is
an interesting challenge but it's also
an eminently auditable and mitigatable
problem so you can imagine human
auditors going through voting
the voting process just like regular
voters and election officials know that
auditors don't get to put ballots in the
ballot box but they get to play with the
machine so an auditor could play with
the machine in a prescribed way enter
test votes that had better come out
correct and that would be and since the
machine can't tell whether it's a real
voter versus an audit voter that's a way
that you might be able to catch machines
if they're cheating that and other
processes like it can help us mitigate
against the increased risk of malware
when it's in the loop of the voter
uh entering their vote preferences yeah
and because we're running out of time
i'm gonna you know punt any detailed
answer
to some other opportunity but i will say
that one thing we've tried hard to do
with with election guard is staying
neutral on this many people prefer
handmark paper ballots for many reasons
election guard is perfectly capable of
working in systems with handmark paper
ballots there are many reasons why some
voters can't use handmark paper ballots
and have preferences for ballot
marketing devices election guard works
there as well
we are trying to stay out of those those
questions and concerns and make election
of guard available to be used however a
local jurisdiction prefers to use it
yep and one of the cool parts about
election guard is the core library is a
bunch of low-level crypto primitives and
then above that there are election
abstractions like ballots and then above
that there are abstractions like tallies
and so the layers of the election guard
software allow themselves to be easily
adapted to these different use cases
yeah
it's designed to be flexible and open
source so that you can adapt it as you
wish where we could we're happy is
microsoft and dan to work with you and
try to see what your use cases may be
and learn and make adaptations and not
just open source it's also open spec
so
all the specs are written down with all
of the equations
and you know in many cases i typed the
equations in and they worked in one case
i typed the equation and found a counter
example and i'm like hey josh i don't
think this exponent is right and you
know we're we're reasonably confident
now that the spec and the implementation
are all doing the right thing
indeed indeed
so um thanks everybody um i i hope that
we've answered all your questions and
please feel free to contact me or dan i
presume if you want to learn more
and we're happy to continue answering
questions
and hope that
you be interested in using this
technology and maybe even have a chance
to vote with this technology in coming
years
thank you all for joining us it was a
real pleasure